what do you think of when you think of a
battery
for most it's what we use to power
devices for both work and play and maybe
even your car
over the past few decades they've gotten
way more powerful long lasting and
affordable
[Music]
but all of this is just a prologue to
what the next batteries are going to do
as we drive to a increasingly renewable
power driven grid we also need to be
able to store energy and release it
later to cover those periods of weather
intermittencies that are driving this
new grid that we're in
it's a multi-trillion dollar opportunity
and it's imperative that we figure out
the solution here
how we store energy on a massive scale
is in many ways the central challenge of
the fight to stop climate change and the
solutions we're coming up with might not
be what you think
[Music]
the need for massive batteries stems
from an aspect of electricity that we
don't often think about so when we make
electricity we produce it and we use it
almost instantaneously because of this
inability to store
when we turn on a button or switch on a
light
at that very moment somebody somewhere
has generated electricity for you to be
able to do that
that exact electricity that's making
that light just had to be produced
somewhere within about a minute
it's very very
new the power that we use
if there's not enough electricity being
produced we get what we all know
actually which is called a brown out
which means there's not quite enough
electricity coming in to power stuff
and
if you have too much electricity that
will also bring down the system
so you can't produce a lot more than
you're using and you can't produce a lot
less than you're using
for most of the grid's history this
hasn't been much of a problem we've
gotten our power from steady reliable
sources like coal plants and
hydroelectric dams
but now of course that's all changing
we can adjust the coal-fired power plant
how much electricity it's making
but we can't adjust how much wind a wind
turbine is making
wind and solar power can't always give
us the juice right when we need it
but if we could save up energy from
renewables and release it when it's
needed clean energy could be as reliable
as coal
the amount of energy storage we need is
going to grow because we're going to
have to rely on solar and wind which are
more intermittent
but it's also going to grow because the
pure amount of electricity that we are
going to use growing forward is going to
grow
so dozens of companies are working on
gigantic batteries hoping to store
enough energy to kick our fossil fuel
habit
[Music]
and one of the biggest batteries
is this mountain
[Music]
light power we are today the largest
portfolio of operating renewable energy
and energy storage in the new england
region
we are using a mountain as a giant
battery that's what we do here
being here inside northfield mountain
it's an incredibly unique facility
we are carved out of the inside of a
mountain it is a facility that dates
back 50 years and yet at the same time
is ideally situated to drive the energy
transition of the future
so pump storage is the oldest form of
energy storage
[Music]
it's essentially transferring water from
an upper reservoir to a lower reservoir
and back and forth throughout the day
our lower reservoir is the connecticut
river which is flowing by about a mile
from where we're standing and then our
upper reservoir is a man-made dam
essentially on top of a mountain
[Music]
water is pumped up to the upper
reservoir and stored for whenever it's
needed later
and then it flows down through turbine
generators to generate electricity
if that sounds like a giant battery
charging and discharging well
exactly
so what we're looking at here is one of
the four units
at northfield in pump mode
so right now we are pumping water from
the connecticut river to the upper
reservoir
later on we'll use that same water spin
the machine the other direction and
generate electricity
when we're standing at northfield
mountain we're talking about 1200
megawatts of instantaneous power
we can provide enough power to support
roughly a million new england homes on
any given day
pumped hydro storage is more than a
century old
it was initially used to be able to just
generate hydropower when you wanted it
and then in the 70s when you had the
creation of nuclear power where power
plants had to be run all the time even
when there wasn't demand for electricity
pumped hydro storage became the stores
of excess electricity
atomic energy the reality for homes and
factories and schools all over the world
but today with the nuclear industry in
decline the mountain has had to find a
new niche to fill
so rather than pairing with nuclear
power
we're a great pair to solar or wind or
other intermittent renewables
offshore wind has been a long time
coming in new england it's been on the
drawing books for a number of years but
we are now seeing the first very large
projects come to fruition so the
opportunity for a facility like
northfield mountain is to provide that
balance to
large-scale offshore wind and store it
for times when that electricity is
needed
unfortunately mountain-sized batteries
do have some unique limitations
the trouble is that pumped hydro storage
requires a specific kind of geography
typically hills with either a river or
lots of access to water in form of
rainfall that is consistent to be able
to make it an economical project that
you can build and then operate for
decades to come and that's not always
feasible because of the lack of
mountains or lack of water some of the
obstacles facing you know large scale
build-out of new pump storage projects
one is cost these projects are billion
dollar projects now they require ongoing
significant capital investment to make
sure that they can continue to run
reliably
and eventually we will run out of how
much pumped hydro storage can do so
we're going to have to need other
solutions as well
to fill those gaps
farm energy is developing the kind of
energy storage you need to enable the
complete decarbonization of the electric
system
it's a battery that's dramatically
cheaper than anything else that's out
there today
and is also made of materials that scale
to the size of the challenge
co-founded by former tesla vp matteo
jaramillo form energy is making a new
kind of battery they hope can store
energy on a massive scale
an iron air battery
when we talk about batteries we kind of
think of these black boxes but really
what goes inside that back box can be
very different chemistries and different
metals that enable those batteries to do
different things
take the example of lithium-ion
batteries
these are what go inside electric cars
in a car you wanted to go fast so you
wanted to draw electricity at very high
rates from the battery into the car and
then drive it forward
lithium-ion batteries are super powerful
but relatively expensive
batteries that store massive amounts of
energy on the grid are going to have to
be way cheaper in order to build them at
scale
to be able to build a battery that is
really cheap
one of the things that you're going to
require is using materials that are very
cheap
iron is really really cheap and it's
really really abundant in the earth's
crust and if anybody's familiar with
iron it's that it rusts so we are
rusting and unrusting iron that's the
battery
when iron takes on oxygen that means
it's giving off an electron
that process which is really a chemical
reaction a nuisance for most of us is
also a process that generates energy
which could be converted into
electricity
and then when you want to store
electricity into that battery you
convert that rust back into iron and
that's really how simple that battery is
it's never been commercialized before
but it has been understood for about 50
years so this is the iron material
which is in these pellets
[Music]
there will be many many kilograms in
each repeat unit of the cell
[Music]
so i set this cell to charge i'm putting
energy into it
and when we do that charge process we
unrust the iron
the big things that you can see on the
outside of this battery are iron
electrodes
and then we generate oxygen
so the oxygen comes off in tiny tiny
little bubbles and they flow around on
the inside
we're standing in front of an incubator
full of subscale cells that we are
testing so these are miniature versions
of the big cell that we use to test out
different material combinations
different designs different conditions
that we cycle the batteries under and we
have 2000 of these all over this lab
[Music]
it is still the scrappy problem-solving
atmosphere of a startup even though
we're getting bigger
and
constantly problem solving on your feet
trying things that have never been tried
before
form energy has been going strong in the
last couple of years raising more than
350 million dollars to date but an
entirely new battery chemistry like this
still has a long road ahead to prove
itself
it took about 30 years from when the
first lithium-ion battery was put in a
camcorder
to it becoming a mainstream battery that
powers all electric cars in the world
in air batteries are going to have to do
that but in a much more compressed
period
form energy has only been around for
about five years
and is going to have to show its
commercial applications within the next
five years that's shrinking the
development time down to a third and
that's no easy challenge
so as we're commercializing this iron
air chemistry for the first time the
challenge is to demonstrate
unequivocally with data that it is a
reliable durable piece of infrastructure
that scales to the existing
infrastructure that's out there so we
are already building at the intended
production scale so this is a meter cube
device that we have and we're already
producing those devices today
[Music]
the idea of the energy transition can
seem daunting
the current energy system just works
aside from the whole melting the planet
thing
but the gigantic battery industry is
growing fast and other solutions are
gaining steam as well like storing
energy with compressed air or using
hydrogen as a clean fuel
a total carbon free grid is getting
easier and easier to imagine it's just a
question of whether we can get there in
time
we are going to i think as a society
really have to embrace our ability to do
big things to build a large energy
infrastructure if we're going to succeed
and what is the defining challenge of
our time and that is building a clean
energy system for
the future
it's quite easy for us to know what
success looks like for farm energy and
that is having the impact at scale on
the decarbonization effort for the
electric grid and that is measured at no
less than gigatons so
billions of tons of carbon that do not
have to be released into the atmosphere
any longer
it's really nice to be
working on something that i think is
actually going to make a difference in
the world
makes me a little more motivated to do
my work
to feel like it's actually going towards
something i care about a lot
and as an engineer
that the problems i'm solving are
problems that matter
[Music]
you